you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
wildfires continue to rip through turkey
italy and greece
as forecasters say temperatures could
reach a record high in europe of 49
degrees this week how climate change is
threatening the availability and
quality of water around the world
and trying to green the construction
material responsible for more emissions
than aviation and deforestation
combined
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions
and we start today with wildfires that
are continuing to rage in turkey greece
and
italy in turkey whole villages and
beaches have been evacuated
with coastal areas amongst the worst
affected
flames have surrounded the tourist
resort of marmarus with residents
forced to flee as their homes were
destroyed
more than 100 firefighters are battling
to bring the fires
under control in the italian city of
pescara on the adriatic coast people
ran from the beach when they spotted
smoke and flames
rising from a nearby forest more than
100 people have been evacuated after
wildfires swept through the italian
coastal town
several people were injured when they
tried to extinguish flames that had
reached their homes
in greece wildfires have destroyed more
than 3 000 hectares of
pine and olive groves in the country's
west since saturday
the country's prime minister said that
greece is experiencing its
worst heat wave in more than 30 years
so what's behind this well temperatures
in this region would normally be around
the high 20s
to low 30s but in recent days we've seen
them hit
10 to 15 degrees above average and those
figures
are set to continue tomorrow and into
the rest of the week
well the heat is building because of a
blocking area of high pressure
in the upper atmosphere now the native
air mass
over southeast europe was already hot
and the prolonged spell of high pressure
has exacerbated the hot and dry
conditions it's all to do with
subsidence as high pressure causes the
air to sink which warms it
and then the heat builds in other words
it creates a heat
dome while high temperatures will
continue around the mediterranean and
balkan peninsula
this week maximum temperatures will
range from the high
30s to mid-40s and a few spots could
reach 47
to 49 degrees and this would challenge
the european record
of 48 degrees which was set in greece in
1997.
sky's special correspondent alice
crawford is in bodrum in turkey and has
witnessed the ferocity of the fires
first hand look at this fire that's just
a spark has just landed right next to us
um and that shows just how quickly it
can catch a hold we've just come from
down that road look at that road it's
now getting
overwhelmed by fire at the end of that
road
there's a small village of several
thousand people
um from churchetmi which is a near
bottom
and just within the space of the last 20
minutes or so
the fire has engulfed the whole of our
rear
um road and has come up along the side
and is threatening to overwhelm this
area with there was mass panic
in the village with dozens and dozens of
people
racing to get out of the area including
the firefighters
truckloads of firefighters pulling out
now we arrived there first thing this
morning
and these strong winds are part of the
reason why
it is um really gathering pace
let's move a bit further down kevin
because it's coming further behind us
and i don't want to get cut off
but um just keep going if you can
um and there was a lot of panic
in the village as we were there you can
see it it's coming down the sides of the
the hill there there was a lot of panic
in the village because they were pretty
much on their own
there wasn't uh firefighters uh we
arrived as they were actually taking
bottles of water and pulling out buckets
of
of water from their wells and trying to
douse the flames and protect their
property
temperatures are much higher than normal
they've been at
over 40 degrees centigrade and that is
the forecast for the next
week or so and many are putting this
down to
a real dramatic shift in climate change
turkey's always had seasonal dry periods
it's always had hot weather
this is far far hotter than anyone
anticipated
as i say the worst in at least a decade
and there'll be more on this developing
story as well as all the day's other
climate news on our website skynews.com
climate now which says people are put
off switching from a petrol to an
electric car
because of the high up-front costs the
consumer group analyzed the cost of
owning
three vehicles that are available as
petrol and electric versions
and found it was significantly more
expensive to own the electric version
over three years
the climate change committee says the
transition to electric cars is one of
the most important actions to achieve
the uk's
net zero target
farmers in england have been given an
extra 17 million pounds in funding to
tackle water and air pollution
the government says every farm will have
access to the programme by march
2023 an increase of 60 percent from its
current coverage
the scheme helps farmers to implement
practical solutions like planting
new grassland buffer strips and
establishing
riverside trees
plastic pollution is creating a trap for
young sea turtles who spend their early
years
stuck in some of the worst affected
waters research led by the university of
exeter
found the animals swallow plastic as
they travel on currents in the pacific
and indian oceans
scientists say it could have a
significant impact on population levels
with global efforts to reduce emissions
and limit global warming affecting
everything from transport to food
there's one area proving
harder to tackle construction and more
specifically
cement the active ingredient in concrete
is responsible for around
seven percent of global carbon emissions
but according to a senior environmental
expert
far more needs to be done to regulate
the industry as our economics and data
editor ed conway reports
it is quite literally the foundational
material of modern civilization
concrete in foundations for power
stations like this
in bridges roads buildings and railways
like hs2
it is the very skeleton of britain's
physical economy
so much so that we sometimes take it for
granted but concrete and its crucial
ingredients cement
are now at the heart of a very big issue
indeed
now when you think about net zero what
probably comes to mind cars
planes power stations but arguably
what's happening in
cement plants like this in this country
and around the world is just as if not
more important
for the future of the planet what we do
here is we take chalk and clay and we
introduce it to this rotary kiln that
you can see behind you
where it's heated to 1 500 degrees
centigrade
and converted into cement that matters
because cement production accounts for
about seven percent of global co2
emissions
that's even bigger than all aviation and
deforestation combined
and here's the key thing cement
emissions come from two sources
first the energy used to heat the kilns
but even more so the chemical
reaction going on inside that rotating
tube
this plant uses renewable fuels
essentially processed rubbish for the
energy bit
but that still leaves the chemical
reaction one option is to try to capture
those emissions and put them back
underground
but that won't happen without
intervention you can't expect companies
to do this out of the goodness of their
hearts
so it's got to be regulated and it's got
to be fair
so you know ideally all we should set a
timetable for decarbonizing cement
across the whole of europe every system
can be mixed roughly the same amount of
time
but mighty answer lie here in these test
tubes at the university of sheffield
that's the zero co2 system that's right
that cement in the test tube on the
right was made without any of the direct
carbon emissions caused by traditional
cement manufacturer
can we just replace traditional cement
with this stuff the short answer is no
and that's because one of the biggest
challenges that we have with these
materials with any replacement for
portland cement
is to be able to produce it on a scale
that can meet the demand for cement and
concrete
all of which is why concrete boring
lifeless concrete
is fast becoming the most exciting
dynamic field in climate science
unless we solve these problems net zero
will remain
a pipe dream ed conway sky news
now climate change will increasingly
affect water availability and quality
around the world with devastating
consequences for the most vulnerable
that's according to a new report from
the university of oxford's reach
programme
which found women are disproportionately
affected by extreme weather such as
floods
while heavy rainfall can lead to
outbreaks of disease
as waste is washed into water systems
now the report looked at how risks vary
in different areas for example in cities
the availability and quality of water
can be put at risk from industrial
pollution
and urbanization now to improve climate
resilience
large areas require better coordination
of surface and groundwater supply
and demand management schemes as smaller
urban areas grow
better communication of climate
information will be vital
local forecasts can help avoid water
shortages
reducing inequalities from unreliable
supplies
while those living in rural areas are
highly vulnerable to climate shocks
and the risks aren't shared equally
impacting women more than men
when climate change affects supplies
people have to adapt their livelihoods
without sufficient information on
emerging risks
well dr katrina charles is associate
professor at the university of oxford
and co-director of reach with water
quality
we know with heavy rains it's going to
flush more
animal waste and human waste into the
waterways into water systems so drinking
water irrigation systems
and so on and these are going to cause
more diseases such as
typhoid and cholera on the other hand
when you've got more dry weather
you find that pollution that's going in
the river like industrial pollution
and that that becomes more concentrated
in the river so people are more exposed
to some of the toxic chemicals like
chromium
well let's bring in professor daniel
alargo from the university of nairobi
and principal investigator for reach
in kenya welcome to you tell us about
some of the challenges that you're
facing in kenya when it comes to water
security
among some of the problems that we
experience are too much rain
too little rain very clean water
then very dirty water and
sometimes the water is too far away to
be able to get it
within a reasonable amount of time
there are also other experiences that
people have in relation to the water
issue and that is in terms of uh you
know
agriculture in terms of uh
you know what do we plant during this
season
and what do we expect to reap at the end
of the day
so it ties in a lot also with aspects of
food
security and it also ties in with
aspects of health and in particular
it has been noted in urban areas more
than in rural areas
that the lack of integration of gender
issues into wash programs
is actually disadvantaging women
disproportionately to men
when it comes to accessing the water
resource so these are just some of the
problems that we do experience
so what can you do about them how can
you improve the situation
uh the first thing is we need to
understand our climate system
and that is one of the things that we
ventured to do in this rich project
to get this information on a much more
granular level
to reduce uncertainties and to enable
better quantification
for scenario analysis and also trade-off
analysis
as well as preparing for present and
future risks
professor daniel largo thanks very much
indeed thank you
well that's everything from us for today
on tomorrow's show find out why
countries need to rely
on more than just planting trees to
achieve net zero targets
thanks for watching see you then